too late urge peer pressure coming I
think I'm a sonic screwdriver hey guys
that was the brand new sketch comedy
video over on nacho punch where they put
in the most production quality I've ever
seen in a video I've never been in
something like that I went through like
nine different costume changes I want to
make up a whole bunch of times they put
a bald cap on me they did stuff with my
hair I was with other people there was
all these lighting stuff that I had no
idea what was going on it was absolutely
amazing in the video turned out great so
check it out by clicking this that's
been up purush somewhere somewhere
around here there's been something that
you can click on and go see the videos
so check it out right now thank you guys
so much ever since I got here
in Los Angeles I have had no time to
myself and I and I'm not disappointed in
that I'm actually pretty happy than them
I've been keeping so busy I did table
flip with the game grumps I did that
thing with nacho pond actually like
about a month ago I did that they've
just been working on it ever since and
I've had a chance to go to playlist live
and I will be going to PAX East in about
two weeks here I will be at PAX East um
there's a whole bunch of other youtubers
that are going there I'm actually gonna
be able to meet yamimash in person and
hang out with him and also just the tons
and tons of youtubers that I've had the
benefit of meeting I actually got the
chance just yesterday to go to
Disneyland with a bunch of other
youtubers I got to meet jontron in
person who I am a huge fan of he is just
absolutely hilarious I got to hang out
with angry joe stripping Dodger and a
few of the other guys at maker the maker
of surgeon simulator was there or one of
them but the only one that I know right
now and he's just a really cool guy and
they're just amazingly fun I've only
been in LA for three weeks and so much
stuff has happened and also like the
channel is been doing absolutely
incredibly well with the amazing a
support that you guys have shown me
we're on our way to 2 million we'll be
there in a few weeks here like it we may
hit it while I'm at PAX and I hope that
I'm able to have something up ready for
that special occasion as soon as
possible because we hit 1 million in
October thirty-first and now it's just
now March 31st so that's just a few
months
the future and we're gonna hit two
million before I've been on YouTube for
two years that's that is incredible
I don't even have words to describe how
quickly this has happened and how
grateful I am for this change I wouldn't
have Leah all these opportunities to
meet these cool people do these great
projects to work with all these cool and
very talented people without you guys so
sincerely from the bottom of my heart
thank you guys so much so anyway I'm
gonna make this a short one I don't want
to get to rambling you know I usually do
in these vlogs so in summary the nacho
punch video is available you can click
the link in the annotation or the link
in the description if you haven't seen
tableflip yet is probably my favorite
episode a table flip and I've seen them
all not just because I'm in it but I
mean it's just they've done a lot more
on how they edit the game and you can
actually learn about the game and how to
play it and what is going on you can
keep up with him oh there's something in
my eye
oh I should make a t-shirt that's just
like an outline of me doing this and
going oh there's something in my eye
but anyway um check that out links also
in the description below oh thank you
all the youtubers that I've worked with
and all the youtubers that I will be
working with in the near future and
thank you guys for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye